Hello everyone,
welcome to the focus channel and my name
is Paul.
Hi everyone.
Welcome to my home and today we're going
to look at how I make a lang focus
video.
You know,
it seems like people think I exist
inside a video.
Sometimes I'm walking down the street
and someone sees me and I can tell that
they recognize me,
but 90 percent of the time they don't
actually talk to me.
They just stare at me confused like,
Hey,
isn't that the computer simulated
humanoid from Lang Focus?
Maybe that's because most of my videos
aren't just me sitting in front of the
camera and talking to the camera.
I put a lot of effort into crafting each
video and producing it and basically
creating a new little world that you can
step into today.
I'm basically taking you behind the
curtain and I'm showing you all the
different steps in that process of
creating a length focus video.
So the first thing that I have to do
when making a video is choose a topic.
Now I have a long list of topics in a
word document that I keep on my computer
and in dropbox and I add topics to that
list whenever I get a new idea that
excites me and for the next couple of
months I always have a short list of
topics,
a short list of topics that I want to do
in the near future,
topics that are currently on my mind or
excite me or motivate me to make a
video,
and then once I finish one video,
I look at the shortlist and I choose the
next video and I think which one excites
me the most?
Which one do I really want to do right
now?
Now the reason I do it like that is
because it really takes a lot of work to
get through one of my videos.
So if I'm not really excited about the
topic or if I don't want to learn about
the topic for myself,
then it's just torture to get through
the time and effort required to make a
video.
Now,
just as an example for this video,
let's say that I'm choosing a topic.
Let's say I'm choosing the languages of
Canada because that's the topic that I'm
really excited about right now.
That's really not one of the topics on
my shortlist,
but let's just say it is.
The next step is research.
Nope,
I'm not an expert in every topic that I
cover.
My videos are basically like projects
and I researched the projects.
I dig into the topic and I learned as
much about it for myself as I can and I
share it with you as a way of learning
for myself.
Of course,
sometimes I have background in the topic
if it's a language I've studied or I've
read about before,
but that's not always the case and even
when it's a language I'm familiar with,
I usually dig in and learn things that I
didn't know before making the video and
it's important for people to know that I
don't like people thinking I'm sort of
linguistic superman when I'm not.
I'm just a regular guy who's interested
in languages and likes to learn more
about them.
So back to the topic of research in the
comments for every video there's always
some person says,
hey,
you just copied wikipedia.
No,
not quite bro,
but I often do start by reading a
wikipedia article on the topic just to
get a general sense of it and basically
to see what kinds of things I want to
learn about it,
what kinds of questions I want to ask
and find the answers to and more
reliable sources.
So for this dummy topic,
the languages of Canada,
we're looking right now at a wikipedia
entry and I can see some types of
information that I'd like to look up,
but for this topic I knew immediately
right off the bat that I would need to
look at the stat can website that
Statistics Canada because it has
information on the number of speakers of
different languages and a statistics on
immigration to Canada and that sort of
thing.
And that's the kind of official source
that I like to use whenever possible.
Whenever researching,
there are new questions that come to
mind and I use good old google to find
the answers.
I normally look at lots of different
sources while keeping my eyes open for
academic sources,
and that includes published books as
well as academic papers on the subject.
This is especially true when dealing
with history or historical linguistics
or when researching a language that
isn't very widely studied,
so there aren't a lot of materials about
that language.
For example,
when I made my video on Kurdish,
I almost exclusively used academic
sources because there aren't that many
commercial sources dedicated to learning
Kurdish when dealing with a more widely
studied language.
I often use language learning books,
the commercial type,
because I have a lot of these at home
and they're a good source of information
about the language.
I also use phrase books a lot.
I have a lot of these as well.
Phrase books are good because they
helped you to learn inductively.
If you're that type of thinker and you'd
like to just look at examples and figure
out how the language works based on
examples.
Phrase books are really good for that,
so that's basically what I'm doing when
I analyze sentences in the videos,
when I break down the sentences,
I'm basically doing what I do with
phrasebooks.
I'm looking at the sentences and
figuring out what all the different
parts of the sentence mean.
While researching.
I often use regular nonacademic websites
as well,
for example,
commercial websites or just websites
written by someone who's very interested
in that language and has knowledge of
it,
but when I use regular websites like
that,
I look at a wide range of them and I try
to make sure that the information I use
is backed up by all the different
sources.
I try to make sure the information is
consistent,
but it's important to point out that
when dealing with linguistics,
there's always quite a bit of variety of
information and there are some different
opinions and there's different data
depending on the source.
Even when you're looking at academic
sources,
the next step is writing for almost
every video.
I write a script.
I don't stick to the script 100 percent
of the time.
I use the script as a sort of skeleton
for what I'm going to say and then I can
veer off of that and I can ad Lib and
change things a little bit while I'm
filming the video,
but I do always have a script or almost
always have a script that I worked from
the difficulty of writing the script
basically depends on the complexity of
the topic and research.
I try to present the information to you
as efficiently as possible.
Basically presenting you as much
information as I can in a shorter period
of time as possible while keeping it as
clear as possible.
So I really tried to cut things down to
the core takeaway,
anything unnecessary and make sure that
everything I present is linked to the
other information and basically I try to
make it easy for myself to understand.
I'm someone who gets easily overwhelmed
by a lot of detail,
so I basically rewrite the script until
I can understand it and if I can
understand it,
then I get.
I guess that you can understand it as
well because I know that I get easily
overwhelmed.
The next step is to actually film the
video.
Now,
some people think that this is the
entire video creation process,
but no,
this is the easy part.
This is the least time consuming part.
Filming the video usually takes under an
hour,
but it can take up to about 90 minutes
depending on how long the video is.
So here we're looking at my studio.
Really,
it's just an extra bedroom that I
converted into a studio and I set up a
green screen that my camera and lights
and I actually moved last year.
I moved into a bigger apartment so that
I could set up a studio like this.
This is the camera that I used to film
my videos until early 2017.
It's a Canon Ivis h f r 52.
It's a fairly affordable,
um,
cam quarter.
It costs about $300 I guess,
and it's fairly easy to use except that
it's difficult to get the focus right.
And a lot of people used to comment on
my video saying,
why is your face out of focus?
Or why is this lang focus if you are not
in focus?
And that kind of thing.
Um,
so I really had to get a new camera as
soon as I could afford to do so.
This one right here is my current
camera.
It's a Sony cyber shots are x 100,
it costs about a thousand dollars and
it's much better to focus as much
better.
And just in general,
it's a great camera.
The only thing that I have a problem
with is that digital cameras like this
usually time out after 30 minutes of
video.
So sometimes I'm in the middle of
filming and I don't realize that 30
minutes have passed.
And then later when I checked the video
file,
I see that the ending was cut off.
So I have to refilm part of the video.
The hardest part about filming is the
lighting.
Knowing where to put the lights,
how close I should be to the lights,
um,
how bright they should be,
what kind of light bulbs to use,
that sort of thing.
You guys probably don't notice it when
you watch youtube videos,
but lighting is essential.
I actually have two lights near me right
now.
There's this one over here and there's
another one in front of me,
uh,
just outside of this room.
Let's just warm up for a minute and talk
and talk and talk and talk some more and
then get into talking with this clear
voice while I'm breathing so that I
don't hyperventilate.
I am right now.
And just get into it normally as I
always do.
Okay.
Just going to talk for a minute,
get warmed up,
get into the zone so I can speak
normally as I always do on camera,
just like this,
except this time it's going to be about
French,
which isn't really different than usual
except that the topic is different and
that's why I'm just doing another video
just like this.
It's no different than usual except that
I'm wearing a blue shirt and the green
screen is behind me,
but that's the same.
And I've got this time.
I'm not going to hold the phone in front
of the camera.
I'm going to be very careful not to do
that.
And it's also hot in this room.
So I have some water and I have a towel
just in case I start to sweat a lot.
Hopefully that won't be a problem in
this video.
I guess we'll see while filming a video,
I usually have my iphone in my hand.
Sometimes you might see my iphone pop up
into the screen when I fail to keep my
hands down low where they should be.
I use the iphone for two things.
First of all,
I have a script on the screen which I
refer to when necessary.
And also it connects to a microphone.
You can see right here,
I'm wearing a level II or microphone.
This is the smart lab.
This is the rode smartlav leveling or
microphone,
which is quite good,
uh,
cost about $100 button.
It gets something near to studio
quality.
So I quite like it and I use the road
recording app on the iphone and you can
see that that the audio file is being
recorded as I speak right now.
And later I can use dropbox to deliver
the file to my computer and then pop it
into the editing software.
And it's all very easy.
And convenient,
the next step is to find the images that
I want to include in the video,
so I read through the script and I tried
to imagine what kind of images I want to
include,
what kind of images should accompany my
voice and the narration.
This includes background images like
scenery or maps or sometimes a photos of
people from a certain country.
If I'm talking about that country,
sometimes historical photos,
that kind of thing.
I often use a site called Pixabay,
which is a source of copyright free
images submitted by users,
so the images are all free and it's
actually pretty good.
I think a lot of professional
photographers upload some of their
photos to picks a bay just to get some
exposure or just for fun or whatever.
I also buy some stock images as well as
using some public domain images or
noncommercial images.
I put all of these images into folders
on my computer so that I can find them
in the next step during the editing
process.
That brings me to the next step,
which is editing.
Now this is another very time consuming
parts of making a lang focus video.
The editing software I use is called
Sony Vegas,
which is all right.
It's pretty good.
There might be some better software out
there like adobe premier or something,
but I just stick to what I know.
Sony Vegas is familiar to me so I just
keep using it.
The first thing I do when editing is I
take the video and audio files from the
filming process and I lined them up on
the timeline so that the audio from my
mic lines up with the audio from the
camera and then I turn off the cameras
so that all you hear is the audio from
the level ear mic.
So right now let me play you something
using just the audio from the mic.
Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul,
but if I turn on the audio from the
camera,
it sounds like this.
Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul,
so you get a much cleaner sound if you
remove the cameras,
echoey audio.
After that,
what I do is go through all the footage
and I cut it.
I removed all of the pauses and that
remove anything that I've repeated,
like sometimes I repeat the same
sentence several times just to get the
delivery right and when I'm editing all
listen to all of the versions and
they'll take away all the ones I don't
want and just keep the best one so it
usually takes a couple hours just to go
through the footage and cut it down.
A typical 10 minute video probably
begins with about 45 minutes to an hour
of footage and then I cut it down to
about 10 minutes.
Next I removed the green screen
background using the Chroma key
function.
I'm basically removing everything that's
bright green so that it becomes
transparent and that means that I can't
wear a green shirt because I'll become
transparent,
but you can see that my green screen
doesn't actually cover the entire space
behind me because of the layout of the
room.
There's just not a lot of space to put
the green screen rack in there.
So the positioning is kind of awkward.
So I have to create a mask and cut out
everything that's outside of the green
screen.
Okay.
So now that there's nothing behind me,
we're ready to place an image behind me
there.
Look guys,
I'm in a classroom,
as you've probably noticed.
I use a lot of visual elements in my
videos and the large amount of
information that I try to cram into one
video means that I have to include a lot
of visual detail and arrange it so that
it's all clear.
While editing,
I make a lot of infographics now.
This can be a very time consuming
process because of how detailed
languages and linguistics can be and
what looks like one infographic to you
is actually a lot of different files so
that I can animate the graphic and make
different elements gradually appear on
the screen.
I make these infographics screens using
a couple of different tools.
One of them is picmonkey and the other
is paint.net.
Depending on exactly what functions I
need to use at the moment while I'm
editing the video,
I take the images that I've gathered and
the screens I've created and I import
them into the Sony Vegas Media Library
so that I can arrange them and layer
them on the timeline.
I also add any audio that I need to the
timeline.
Sometimes I have to rerecord some parts
of the audio because the sound was
muffled or because I said one word wrong
or something like that,
and I also sometimes use audio from
volunteers like language samples from
volunteers.
When I find volunteers to record some
language samples for a video,
I usually do that during the editing
process.
If you follow Lang focus on facebook,
you've probably seen me post a request
for volunteers.
For example,
I'm making a video on Greek.
I need a volunteer speak Greek or
something like that.
Uh,
and I get a lot of responses.
Then I choose one or two people and they
record their samples for me.
I can't choose everyone,
but I'm grateful for all of the offers.
So after I have those audio clips from
the volunteer,
then I add those onto the timeline and
that's usually one of the last steps of
the editing process.
So you see I'm wearing these glasses
right here.
These glasses are actually blue
blockers.
They help block out the blue light from
my computer screen and from the lights I
use while filming and all of that blue
light I guess ignites your brain and
keeps you up at night.
It makes it harder to sleep because your
mind is activated.
So by wearing these like just block out
that light and rest a little bit more
easily when I go to sleep.
So these are quite helpful.
I wear these every day after editing.
The next step is to choose music usually
after editing sometimes earlier,
but typically after editing I get music
from a few different sources.
One of the main ones is the youtube
audio library,
which is a source of copyright free
music that Youtube creators can use for
free.
And some of us end up using the same
songs,
the same tracks.
So sometimes in the comments I get
comments like,
Hey,
you stole that song from h three,
h three,
or hey,
that's the dubs content cop song or
something like that.
But in reality we all got those songs
from the same source,
from the Youtube Audio Library and there
are other sources of copyright free
music as well.
Some of them are youtube channels that
offer copyright free music.
Some of them are websites,
but it can be a little hard to find
something suitable so you might notice
the same music in several different
videos on my channel.
That's because when I find something
good,
it's hard not to use it again.
After adding music.
The next step is audio mastering,
so I go through all the footage through
the whole video,
listening to each individual audio clip,
making sure that everything is
consistent,
that the volume is about the same and
that the quality of sound is about the
same for all the different clips.
This includes adding audio compression
and also eat q to bring out the right
frequencies and if there are audio
samples from a volunteer,
they often have a different sound to
them and they can get lost in the mix
quite easily,
so I try to eat q them so that they are
clear on standout.
The final step is rendering.
Rendering means you're creating the
final video file,
so basically the editing software,
Sony Vegas takes all of the individual
clips from the timeline and puts them
all together and create one file out of
them.
This can take a long time depending on
your computer and depending on how long
the video is and depending on how many
different files are on your timeline.
With my current computer,
it typically takes around an hour to
render a video,
but on my old computer at sometimes
three or four hours while the video is
rendering,
I put together a thumbnail using
picmonkey.
There's usually an image of myself in
the thumbnail and that's not because I
want attention or because the video is
supposed to be about me or something
like that.
It's really not.
I just do this as a way of my channel
because when people who like Lang focus
see me in the thumbnail,
they know that I have a new video and
they click on it immediately.
I try to make the thumbnail,
catch people's eye using a background
image behind me and using some texts
that stands out and I also run the
thumbnail through a filter sometimes
like through a photo filter,
the way people do on instagram.
I don't notice a lot of other youtube
creators doing this,
but I find it gives us sort of,
um,
interesting,
unreal effect to the thumbnails.
So once the video is finished,
rendering of the thumbnail is ready,
then I upload them to youtube on my old
Internet connection.
This used to take hours and hours.
Sometimes it took six hours to upload a
video,
but currently I have vdsl internet and
it only takes like five or 10 minutes,
which is heaven.
After adding a title tags and
description to the video,
then it's time to publish it and share
it to social media so that all you
wonderful people know about the video.
This is actually quite important because
youtube judges the importance of a video
based on view velocity,
the number of views that the video gets
in a shorter amount of time right after
it's released,
so if I upload a video and a lot of you
immediately watch it.
If a thousand of you watch it in the
first two minutes,
then youtube says,
hey,
this must be an important video,
and they share it with other people that
promote it more,
but on the other hand,
if only a couple of you watch the video
in the first couple of minutes,
Youtube says,
oh,
his fans don't care about this video.
It must suck.
Let's not promote it.
This happened with my video on Japanese.
The original thumbnail of the video
wasn't the typical Lang focus thumbnail
style.
I didn't appear in the thumbnail and it,
it just looked different so people
didn't realize it was my video at first
and the number of people who clicked on
the thumbnail in the first couple of
minutes was lower than usual and youtube
set up.
This video isn't worth promoting.
So the video really struggled to get as
many views as it should have,
so that means when you guys rushed to
watch one of my videos and you write
first in the comments and that's
actually a good thing.
So that's the basic approach I take to
making a lang focus video.
My experience making the video is
probably quite different from your
experience watching the video.
It's really a lot of hard work and I
regularly clock 100 hours making a
single video.
Uh,
I'm trying to cut that down actually.
I'm trying to do more concise,
shorter videos on narrower topics
basically for my own sanity and to make
a,
to make everything more sustainable over
a long period of time.
But I do intend to keep making videos
that I hope you find interesting and
educational and motivating,
which is really the goal of losing focus
and has been since the start.
So shall we do a question of the day as
usual?
Sure.
Why not?
Was there anything about the video
making process that stood out to you or
surprised you?
Let us know in the comments down below.
If you don't follow Lang,
focus on facebook,
twitter,
or instagram,
please do at least one of those,
and I'd like to say thank you again to
my patrion supporters,
especially these people right here on
the screen who are my highest tier of
Patrion supporters.
Thank you very much to them and to all
my patrion supporters.
This video is actually a patrion
milestone video.
I made this video to celebrate reaching
a certain goal on Patrion,
so thanks to all of my supporters who've
helped me reach that goal.
If you'd like to become a patron as
well,
if you'd like to support me on Patrion,
then please visit patrion.com/lang
focus.
But that's completely optional.
It's up to you.
I'll never hold it against you if you
don't,
so don't even stress about it.
Alright.
Thank you for watching.
I hope you found this type of video
interesting.
Thank you for watching and have a nice
day.